Before we begin, we should take
a moment to discuss API usage limits.
It is important to Google that
developers have access to
as much capacity as they
need to be successful.
And so, usage of the Google Places API
for Android is free and unlimited for
all apps.
However, to ensure fair use by all apps,
there are tiered query
limits on some methods.
The Places API enforces a default limit
of 1000 requests per 24 hour period.
There's another checkpoint when your
average is 150,000 requests per day.
If you exceed either of these
thresholds, your app may start to fail,
as further API calls are denied.
So to avoid this,
we have a simple review process in
place to be granted a higher limit.
Instructions on this review process can
be found in the documentation linked,
in the instructor notes below.
But because of these usage limits,
in order to use the API,
you will need an Android API Key.
If you fail to provide this, you may
notice that the Place Picker widget will
launch, and then immediately close.
It's an interesting
error to try to debug.
So to get properly configured, and
create your API Key, you need to return
to the Google Developer console.